[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
ramsay personality george campbell
joined today by the inimitable ken
coleman oh host of the ken coleman show
best-selling author and we are here to
take your calls take your questions
maybe it's about money maybe it's about
work your purpose a toxic boss you're
looking to change jobs you're looking to
move sell a house buy a car there's a
thousand things rattling around in your
brain and we want to help you take the
right next step for your future
so phone lines are open triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number to call that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five jeremy's
kicking us off in green bay wisconsin
jeremy welcome to the ramsay show
hey there how you doing great
great how can we help today
well i just wanted to get some advice on
we recently sold our home but we're
selling our home we haven't closed yet
but
and we're going to get a pretty good
chunk of proceeds back some of that is
allocated already to paying off for
chapter 13 in full
and
the rest of it i'm kind of trying to
figure out what the best thing to do is
um
when we get the proceeds it will be 100
debt free
cars will be paid for chapter 13 be paid
back in full and then the only thing
left hanging out there would be a 401k
loan that we use as original down
payment
through my work and
if we don't pay off the check excuse me
if we don't pay off the
401k loan we're going to come up with
about 80 000 in proceeds left to us at
the end of the day
the 401k loans like 25k
okay so what are the proceeds from this
home sale
the entire proceeds are 180
185
yes okay what's the total debt including
the 401k loan
to get out to pay off the chapter 13.
uh 100
well it's 101
100 000 plus the 25 so 125. okay so even
after paying off
everything you still have another 60k
correct
that is a good spot to be in after going
through what you guys have been through
where are you going you sold the house
or you're in the process where were you
planning to go buying another house
renting what's what's going on
uh
sorry we're renting right now
um we're planning to build a new home
hopefully in the next couple years
okay so you're going to rent for a while
and you get 60 grand
correct yeah that's a good spot to be in
yeah i would rent for a while i don't
know the stipulations as far as when
you're going to be able to get a
mortgage again have you looked into that
i have and that's kind of part of why
i'm unsure if we take the 401k loan and
pay that off right away or we wait
because we'll need 20 down so we did
find something in the next you know six
months to a year
um dude you got to pay the 401k
that thing is gone
we've gotta we've gotta start building
for the future and right now you're
trying to pay for the past while
building for the future and it's gonna
leave you in a risky spot so i would pay
off all of your debt i would have a
fully funded emergency fund you guys
will you guys have that obviously with
the 60 part of that will become the
emergency fund if you don't
sure so what's the emergency fund is
like three months expenses right 36 3 to
6.
okay how stable is your income and your
family's income
i'm very stable
okay
yeah i mean if you want to lean towards
six after what you guys have been
through i'd have some whiplash i'd want
to have as much financial peace as much
foundational security as possible
okay so then would that kind of start
back out we would essentially be at your
step number three correct yes
and then you'd be saving up for the down
payment
which yes it may take a little while but
i'm okay with that because man you
clearly have been rushing into some
financial decisions that led you to
where you guys are and i want you to
never ever have to go back to that again
so we've got to focus on behavior change
instead of just math and what's going to
work for the down payment i don't care
if it takes you two three four five
years to save that down payment right
now we've got to focus be focused on
intentional decisions over a long period
of time jeremy what's the income
household income
uh take home or annual just give me the
annual or
150k a year yeah awesome yeah i mean so
you guys are gonna have a fully funded
emergency fund and then you've got a
good decent chunk started towards a 20
down payment you but listen i i don't
hear on you
the joy that i would like to hear on you
because you're like well the down
payment right no get rid of all that
debt man you are free you are clear you
want to talk about a fresh start and
honestly not just a fresh start but a
healthy start a fully funded emergency
fund and a percentage toward the 20
you can rent your renting anyway you're
not wasting money
jeremy i'd like to hear a little more
juice out of you man this is awesome
yeah thank you it's it's a little
nerve-wracking i guess just trying to
make sure that we don't get ourselves
into the scene
exactly that's always so slow what would
what would have to be true for you to
get yourself back into the mess you just
are about to clean up what would have to
be true
i'm probably just not making a
strongly educated decision
yeah so are we going to ever take out
another 401k loan yes or no
are we going to take out any kind of
debt at all ever again
no okay great news there was too much
hesitation there i wanted to find a car
no yeah i i yeah i mean look dude
there's nothing for you to be nervous
about
nothing
at all
when the time comes george let's finish
this out
you've paid off your house yeah you have
zero credit score you teach people all
the time you can buy a house
without oh yeah
with no debt with no credit nothing you
can buy a house tell him how he's gonna
be able to do it in two or three years
manual underwriting or a no score loan
is what you want to look for our friends
at churchill mortgage they do these all
day every day and this is the right way
to do it because you're not playing the
credit score game which let me remind
you involves playing the debt game you
gotta get into debt pay it off perfectly
don't add too much don't pay too much
off too quickly that's the most insane
part people get mad because they pay off
debt and their credit score goes down
and we go yeah the system is rigged man
so jeremy you can rise above this entire
system
once and for all and i know you guys
have been through this bankruptcy and
that's got to be heart wrenching and i
want you to look at that as your never
again moment and that is why i want you
to do this slow pay off all the debt get
the emergency fund to a healthy place
then we can focus on getting the down
payment you'll get there you guys have a
fantastic income you've got your whole
life ahead of you how old are you
i'm 38. oh my 30-ish
a great do-over
and you still have an incredible life to
live you got a family
yep i do a wife and two kids i want
those two kids to be the reason you get
up every day and bust your butt and to
make that money to put yourself in a
place where you have financial peace
and if you do that the low and slow way
man
you're going to be in a totally
different place just a few months from
now a few years from now where you never
have to hear from a collector again you
never have to deal with a bankruptcy
judge again you never have to play the
credit score game again that's what this
plan is all about simplicity and freedom
are you on board with that jeremy sure
yes sir
all right there it is i feel like that's
as much as we're gonna get from jeremy
he gave us all the juice that he could
he gave us he gave it to us he's excited
we appreciate it man hey listen if you
want to learn more about bankruptcy we
did a whole episode on the fine print
our podcast on the ramsey network
episode eight is bankruptcy a quick fix
for struggling americans it was
eye-opening police hold up your popcorn
it's actually entertaining thank you ken
appreciate that hey more of the ramsay
show coming up
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by my
co-host ken coleman we are taking your
calls triple eight eight two five five
two two five
so this week we announced that our
building wealth live event is coming to
both las vegas and orlando this may and
building wealth is a hot topic right now
everyone and their brother and their
mother-in-law has an opinion on how to
do it whether it's crypto single stocks
or zero down real estate on top of that
inflation has everyone freaking out and
so they're looking for some
get-rich-quick schemes to combat it so
we're going to walk you through what's
going on today and teach you how to
build real wealth the financial
principles we teach are the only
principles
that work in prosperous times and in
hard times it is the quickest and surest
way to become what we call a baby steps
millionaire so join me dave ramsey
rachel cruz dr john dolone and ken
coleman as we unpack these principles
and hot topics
so las vegas we're coming to you on
thursday may 5th orlando we're coming
your way on thursday may 19th and stay
tuned because we're going to have more
events coming this fall we're back
and uh i'm gonna i gotta talk to uh
to uh pete uh our vp of live events i
think we should get a tiger for the
stage in vegas it feels right i won't be
on that stage i'll tell you that much me
and a tiger don't mix
well hey tiger or not for just 25 bucks
you can attend this event and we've got
a really cool deal you can get a four
pack for only 60 bucks for those of you
doing the math that brings it down to 15
a ticket if you can find three friends
by the way we should point out right
here i think there's potential confusion
with these talking points some of these
ramsay folks
all right they're budget conscious they
hear four pack that is not chicken
tenders that is tickets that's fair four
pounds i just want
a bundle a ticket bundle if you will
yeah yeah you start talking about a four
pack and people start looking for fries
and coke with them producer james got
hungry there he did he this is a four
pack this is a great deal so don't wait
on this because the tickets are selling
super fast these events will sell out go
to
ramseysolutions.com
events if you want to learn more let's
go to the phones kaylee joins us up next
she's in madison wisconsin hey kaley
welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
absolutely how can ken and i help today
um so i'm just going because my husband
and i recently got into a position where
we are struggling to
pay for our firm walls so i just wanted
to kind of get some advice from you guys
oh i'm so sorry kaylee
what happened
yeah um so well basically um my i am a
financial analyst um in madison
wisconsin
and i'm making sixty thousand a year and
i also received a three thousand dollar
bonus this year
um my husband is a real estate agent
here and
with the healthy market it's been just
you know a little rough um
we also have three kids so um
right now we're paying like two thousand
dollars a month in child care
um so basically after all of our
expenses we have
like three hundred dollars left for
groceries
so
i've just been wondering um what we
should do to change um i have a
2019 honda pilot um
with 34 000 miles on it so
i bought it for 36 000 and i can sell it
for probably like 35.
um
we also were gifted the mutual funds
last year um 106 000 so
quite a bit of money
um so we have some things to fall back
on but um kaylie let me ask you let me
ask you this real quick george george
will walk you through all of this and
and but we need to find out a little bit
more so how much money is your husband
making as a real estate agent
um well it totally depends on
like the month um
you know he made like forty thousand
dollars in in a couple months and then
it was like
just offers now i'd listen i totally
understand but i mean if you look at
last year the year before
what's what's he making what's the
average
um well we just did our 2021 um
taxes and our taxable income was 80 000.
okay but you make 60.
um yeah after taxes like after
healthcare and
dental and um okay and then
what kind of debt do you guys have how
much
um well in december we just paid off all
of our debts so so you're definitely
part of our house our yes
yeah we paid off our house our car and
79 thousand dollars
wow
way to go yeah we've been working really
hard but um i feel like we just like hit
a wall
well kaylee i want to just encourage you
that you guys are are not in a dire
situation i know it feels like that
because of the child care and there's
not a lot of margin in your budget but
you're you don't have any payments to
anyone except the mortgage right
um we paid our house off so it's
literally just like hold on you guys
have no payments in the world
even making 60k in madison there's no
money left over to eat and put food on
the table and get gas in the car
so after
um
like my take-home pay is 3 400 a month
um and child care is 2 000 a month um
utilities are
about to on average uh like 250 a month
um
our car insurance maintenance gas around
214 a month
and then it's just you know fifty
dollars for my school and seventy five
dollars for internet and then
250 dollars we have our kids in some
sports right now
um so it's like 300 some dollars for
groceries it's like it's pretty tight
okay where's this where's this emotion
coming from what is is it because of the
stress of the
very little mark yeah
okay
yeah we just don't know when the next
paycheck's coming um on his side so
like we used our um emergency fund the
last three months so it's gone
now where is it going towards what's
yeah
well okay so we were we had um we were
basically we were overspending um we
were spending more than my income aid
and um
like pulling from his his income like
his income should just be saving but um
we were pulling from it to pay for child
care and
um
anything else like we were eating out so
we're not eating out anymore i cancelled
like apple music audible like is he on
board is he on board with all this i
mean because what i'm trying to piece
together
okay so you guys walk the baby steps out
except for the fact that you didn't
really adhere to the budget you paid off
debt but but you didn't really have a
budget and so you got yourself in
trouble is that what i'm hearing yes
okay can i
okay
so george i don't know if this is money
advices i i got to tell you your husband
needs to stink and put his big boy pants
on and step up and i don't know why he's
not selling houses in madison wisconsin
it's not like you're in the slums i i i
don't have the real estate data in front
of me but if he can't if the housing
market is so slow that he can't sell
houses in madison he needs to get a
better job this is an income issue i
mean you guys need to get your budget in
place but what is he doing
well he's with the kids so we um wait a
second you're spending 2 000 a month on
child care
yeah 18 hours a week is what we can
afford um
that's with our kids um their school
they go to private school so they're in
um their tuition plus child care for our
youngest and then during the summer it's
all three of them so the monthly average
is two thousand dollars a month okay so
here's the deal i'm not picking on your
husband i'm not trying to be unkind do
you agree that this is an income issue
with him he can be and should be making
more money yes or no
yeah oh we've all think we should be
well then he needs to get busy
he needs to get busy we are looking we
are looking right now both of us but we
just like
at the point where it's like he's been
looking at kaylee i want to do i'm going
to give you a gift here i want you and
your husband to go watch all the videos
in financial peace university i'm going
to give you a year to ramsay plus and i
want you to get on a written budget
every month i want to know where every
single penny is going from your income
you make well above the average
household income in america and you
don't have a payment in the world
you don't have debt you don't have a
mortgage there's no excuse that you guys
can't live your life with a little bit
of margin george i got to throw this in
here a practical thing you got to sit
down and be real about maybe pulling
those kids out of private school for a
season a season here's the four walls
food utilities housing transportation if
you get those basic needs covered yes
everything else can go away every
subscription every private school every
sport i don't care right now we've got
to get above water and we got to figure
out what the root of this is and if it's
overspending we're buckling down on this
budget because we can't live like this
you can't live with this much anxiety
you guys work too hard to be this broke
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print joined today by
ken coleman host of the ken coleman show
he's co-piloting today and we are taking
your calls and ken we just took an
interesting call very interesting from
kaylee
in madison wisconsin and she was
very emotional very stressed out a lot
of anxiety trying to keep up with with
their budget their bills their four
walls but the shocking part is
completely debt-free home is paid for
and they make 80 grand a year and it
gets better
have over a hundred thousand dollars in
mutual fund gifts that were recently
given to them and they just burned
through their emergency fund burned
through it for living expenses which
pointed us back to there's an issue here
and she admitted there's been some
overspending over spending so that's the
budget right no don't have a budget
that's one issue the other issue is i'm
just going to tell you
i am old school i think when you have a
income problem you go get your stinking
fanny to work and the guy doesn't need
to be home with the kids and the other
thing we identified is the four walls of
what matters most so what gets cut
two thousand dollars a month in private
school on top of on top of the child
care on top of kids sports
this is over half of their income has
been eaten up by this and i'm sure most
of america they're like yeah that's how
much child care costs ken
tell you what man pay my taxes i'm
sending my kids to the old publicly
funded child care i'm telling
telling sparky to get his butt out and
sell some houses in the hottest real
estate market maybe in the history of
the united states or go get a better job
that's what needs to happen
i think people get stressed and they
back themselves into a corner and they
feel stuck and the best thing to do when
you feel stuck is to go get busy get to
action grab a shovel man so with that
though i wanted to talk about this idea
of protecting your four walls everyone's
experiencing the pain of inflation what
are the four walls george for people who
have never heard that food utilities
housing and transportation yeah if you
have those four things you're gonna be
okay
if you have food on the table you can
pay your light bill your water bill
you've got shelter somewhere to live
and you can pay to get to work a and b
and we're not talking maseratis here
this is just basic needs
then you're gonna be okay and that's the
first thing we tell you to cover before
you cover anything else when you start
our plan so our team just published a
great article called how to combat
inflation and protect your four walls
and we're doing a series here we just
did one on food recently and we're
moving into utilities today to give you
some quick tips again none of these are
life-changing you're gonna roll your
eyes and say okay george shut the lights
off big whoop that's gonna save me big
money but i wanted to walk through some
of this because it really is interesting
so
inflation is the highest rate it's been
in 40 years but 8 percent and since
february 2021 energy prices have gone up
by 25.6 percent
so we've got a few quick tips here on
how to save when it comes to utilities
number one don't run appliances unless
they're full ah not only is that great
advice for money it irritates the stew
out of me when my when kids start doing
that there's three things
two things in the dishwasher yeah let's
pack it out man so uh and what's
interesting ken pre-rinsing waste of
time waste of water the dishwashers
today are made to get the gunk off all
right now i got to tell you something
tell that to steve stepping on my toes
i'm gonna take that home with me i'm not
even kidding right now this was not a
pre-rinse in fact i'm the guy that not
only do i pre-rinse i give it a little
bit of a scrub before i put it in there
why am i doing this now you own a
dishwasher ken you're telling me that i
can put it in there with the caked pasta
that was overcooked in the microwave i
have teenagers do you live on little
house on the prairie what's going on
here man use the dishwasher it's there
for you you didn't answer my question
will it kelly knows i mean come on don't
look at teenagers is not going to save
your cook stuff in the microwave so like
the pasta and the cheese is like
embedded into the plate you're telling
me that the modern dishwasher will get
that off
listen can't i'm not here
i'm not well i'm not here to be the
shamwow pitchman to tell you how your
dishwasher is going to change your life
until i know folks i'm going to continue
with the rinse and light scrub before i
put it in the dish sounds like a
parenting problem
it sounds like a control issue i'm sure
all right moving on number two program
your thermostat i'm one of those
millennials i've got the smart
thermostat this is big so if you're not
gonna be home all day the heat doesn't
have to be pumping through the house you
can save as much as 10 a year if you
drop that thermostat down and i know uh
my wife is one of those who's just
constantly cold so we've got to have the
heat blasting but if you put on a few
layers you'll be okay what do you have
it on in the winter george i'm uh i'm
almost 70. oh that's in the winter
we are 66 degrees
at night in the winter 66. chilly i get
up in the morning and my feet hit the
tile in the bathroom it's like oh
welcome world i'm willing to wait
fast i am willing to pay that premium
too not me i sleep better when it's
colder by the way look it up
sleep sleep studies sure at night i drop
it down to 67. i said at night oh okay i
thought you meant during the day you
said 70. we're on the same page why are
we fighting ken we don't need to be
doing this in front of the kids in front
of america
all right so that's a big one though uh
and smart thermostats can help with this
i have that one really at home super
easy can control from my phones by the
way don't let the kids operate it keep
them away from it get a lock box on when
i was growing up my dad used to threaten
a beating uh you can't say that anymore
but like a real beating if i ever touch
the thermostat it was the no go no not
allowed no touch that's smart we need to
get back to those days we do all right
lastly this is a no-brainer use less so
if energy costs are busting your budget
one of the best things you can try to do
is use less of it and that means being
intentional
even those little things it all adds up
turn off the lights turn off the water
while you brush your teeth all of that
stuff matters get led light bulbs
there's all these little things you
skipped over the light thing and that
should have been a major point george
thanks credit to you thank you first of
all led lights game changer you wouldn't
believe the energy savings they last
longer on top of that and here's the
other thing turn the daggum lights off
can't wait till all my teenagers are
married and in their own homes i'm going
to go to their house walk in every room
turn every light on we're just like the
old curmudgeon guys on like sesame
street in the balcony just telling the
kids to turn the lights off and get off
our lawns i'm just telling you i'm going
to take great pleasure there we go every
light on leaving the refrigerator door
open to that end check your insulation
make sure there's no drafts coming in
make sure things are insulated well
that's going to be big energy windows
change your filters that's a big one you
want to make sure all your appliances
are running efficiently so do a little
audit this weekend and see what happens
next month see if you don't save a few
bucks yeah a lot of people just tuned in
for the first time ever and they think
they're listening to a home improvement
show listen i'm tim the tool man taylor
yeah you wish so you can check out the
blog at ramseysolutions.com it's called
how to combat inflation and protect your
four walls we're going to be going
through some other areas like housing
and transportation coming up on the show
so stay tuned for that all right let's
go to the phones joel joins us in
portland oregon joel welcome to the
ramsay show
thank you and good afternoon gentlemen
how can we help
um i am 35 years old i have never been
in debt in my life um i've discovered uh
this channel on uh on youtube it's been
pretty entertaining to to watch
and um i'm thinking about going in debt
for the first time in my life so i'm
hoping you guys will either endorse me
or maybe talk me off the uh you know
we're not going to endorse you joel
how long have you been watching well
hear me hear me out all right let's hear
him out let's hear about that
no i don't want to hear this out
it'll be entertaining
very
least 30 seconds you have 30 seconds
30 seconds as to why you should get debt
for the first time in your life go
okay so
my my wife and i are stable educated
good income household take-home pay of
about 130 000 a year we own a home
valued probably around 750 thousand
dollars
which we bought from my mother
and for a very very good price and now
we've got this home and we want to start
building a dividend uh snowball we want
to start building something that's going
to start compounding and building up now
we can do what we're doing and save and
pay with cash and do it little by little
but
we've got this valuable thing we're
living in called a house and my wife
said well what if we what if we borrowed
against the house you continue to work
pay pay the bank for the payments but we
can get some cash right away to put in
and get a big snowball it's a horrible
started rather than start with a small
snowball and and uh
these uh some of these dividends are
paying much higher rates than the
interest rate that the bank would be so
uh charging us so is the math not
working out what am i missing
you you've just got a little starry eyed
about the money you could be making when
right in front of you you've got a
fantastic income you have some great
wealth building tools at your disposal a
401k an ira good growth stock mutual
funds don't try to play a shortcut game
man it's gonna end with you getting
burnt and i don't want that for you guys
have done so well there's no reason to
go into debt you guys have this amazing
house a great income you're doing great
you're not behind i think this is the
message if i could share with your wife
you guys aren't behind you're ahead of
the game relax stay the course man your
greatest wealth filling tool is your
income and when you pay it to lenders
you don't get to keep it and you don't
get to build wealth this is the ramsay
show
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i am ramsay
personality george pamela joined today
by ken coleman our question of the day
comes from blinds.com blinds.com's 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color like
ken and i would probably do i've done
that they will remake your blinds for
free true story mismeasured because i'm
an idiot you're not an idiot when it
comes to these kind of things i'm an
idiot it's very stressful yeah they help
me out very good people i apologize
profusely they're like no problem mr
coleman they called you mr coleman yeah
well i like that level of respect yeah
give them a shot yeah so uh with
blinds.com free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more you can use
pro promo code ramsay to get the best
deal today's question comes from brian
in missouri he asks i'm 27 years old and
i have been working in the natural gas
industry since i was 20. i don't have a
degree and i make very good money and
enjoy the work the last few years it has
seemed that our country is moving away
from my industry i have a fear that
later in my career i could be out of a
job is this a rational fear or am i
paranoid should i be looking into other
careers okay brian
first of all i think it's a good
question right it's a forward-thinking
question what's going on in the natural
gas industry are these real trends that
we need to be worried about um or is it
just kind of the ups and downs as we see
new types of energy
become available for consumers two
things on this i'm not a natural gas
expert but i have a hard time believing
that the natural gas industry is going
to completely go away i just don't see
that going away it is still cost
effective and i think it's very viable
however you are in the industry and you
need to talk to real industry experts in
your company
do your homework and figure out is this
something that over time
is going to go completely away that
would be the first question um
so i i don't think that you need to be
fearful i think that you need to be
vigilant there's a difference
i'm looking i'm watching i'm scanning
the future kind of seeing what's moving
but i'm not going to be fearful now the
second thing george
that i would say to brian is
you do a certain type of work
in the natural gas industry
right so you aren't someone who is only
capable of working in that industry
you are in let's call it the energy
industry so therefore whatever you do in
your day-to-day work and the skill set
that you've developed plus the
experience that you've developed is all
going to allow you
to move into multiple different
industries so from that standpoint i
wouldn't be afraid at all yeah i think
these skills are going to transfer to
whatever industry if it even does go
away ken like you're talking about i
don't know that it will in our lifetime
i i honestly can't see it unless natural
gas just becomes a
almost like an extinct resource but i
gotta tell you um
i use it all the time i've got a world
class griddle george it's huge
um and it connects right to the old uh
gasoline natural gas people love it and
i love to cook on it
all over the country fantastic so yeah i
don't see it going away anytime soon but
i think he does have have a right to
stay
afoot he's a smart guy i i would get the
facts unless i start seeing other
natural gas companies shut down layoffs
are happening all around me i see the
writing on the wall but let's not lose
sleep over that right now no that could
be 30 40 100 years from now here's the
key and i want other people to hear this
because this is a relevant question for
a large portion of our audience
your skill set and your experience
is transferable
i'm going to say it again your skill set
and your experience is transferable
you might need to get a certification
here or there
but the bottom line is
you are not stuck in one industry and i
get this call all the time on the ken
coleman show ken i'm a teacher i want to
get out ken i'm a nurse i want to get
out or whatever it is
we hear this the most from our military
men and women they feel like because
they've only had a career in the
military that they they can't get a job
in the private sector and i said wait a
second you you work for one of the great
organizations in the world
and you have skills yes or no and you
have experience
and then where is that transferable in
the private sector the reality is in
today's world our military men and women
are just premium because of their
discipline because of their character
and commitment so don't get too scared
just start looking into it good
encouragement for brian there thanks for
the question
all right open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to call leanne joins us in
macon georgia leanne welcome to the
ramsay show
hey how are y'all doing great how can we
help
um okay so me and my husband are all
babies that too we should be finished
september 2023 nice my husband makes
about 5 000 a month that covers our four
walls and our minimum debt payments
my income is commission based but that's
what we're doing our snowball off of
um
my mother my mother-in-law and my
father-in-law all live on our property
that none of them have any retirement or
any savings they're all in their 60s and
sub-par health
and i'm trying to figure out if we need
to fix our budget to be able to afford
long-term care insurance for them
because they can't
or if it should just be because they
would qualify for
you know well care or welfare whatever
you call that um but i know that's not
the best option so i'm trying to figure
out which route we need to take um
that's a great question and you sound
like
just uh an incredible woman for taking
this on
mom mother-in-law and father-in-law and
they're they're broke
they're unable to work
uh my father-in-law has an amputation so
he he has a disability
my mother-in-law just lost her job two
weeks ago she was laid off
my mom currently works but she has a ton
of debt student loans medical bills
consumer debt just the whole nine yards
well they need to
they need to pay off their debts they
need to be working if they're able to
work i don't want you to take on the
burden of these three folks who have not
done a good job taking care of
themselves because that's going to put
both of you guys in a hole you've got
your own path your own financial journey
you're on i think it's great that you're
letting them live on the property but
they need to get to work if they can and
she needs to get this debt the medical
debt negotiated the student loans paid
off and get back to work i know there's
been some setbacks it sounds like
they're just they're a little bit
downtrodden it sounds like
yeah what was your mother-in-law doing
before she was laid off
she worked in a medical office doing
billing yeah
yeah i got to tell you i mean uh
she replaces that job and and now if
they have some discipline i think i
think george is right i think you're
kind enough to let him live there and i
think if you sit down with them and go
hey we can help you but here's the only
way we can help right now beyond what
we're doing and that is helping you
understand budgeting you know george
let's give them let's give them some
financial resources for the in-laws and
mom here oh absolutely we can definitely
do that so leanne are they paying you
guys anything to live on the property
um they helped pay the like electric
bill because our well is together and
things of that nature and um we have
like we have cows and chickens and they
pay for the feed
so we're talking like 50 bucks a month
this isn't a lot
it's not yeah okay
so therefore any income they do have can
be put to use because they don't really
have living expenses
and so i think they've gotten a little
comfortable living on your property to
be honest and they don't feel like
there's any real rush to get themselves
in financial order therefore you
shouldn't be in a rush to get them in
financial order they have to care more
than you do
bingo bingo bingo leanne i want to make
sure you heard what georgia said i think
he just dropped some absolute truth on
you
and i'm not trying to be unkind to your
your in-laws and your mom there's no
urgency
they don't it doesn't i'm gonna tell you
why and i get it and not knocking on
them it's just this is the human
condition
there's no urgency because their four
walls are essentially taken care of
george has been talking about the four
walls all week
and and so there's no urgency for them
to dig themselves out
you've already done them a big kindness
you don't do not need to enable them
financially by paying for long-term care
paying for any of their debt that is not
on you those are decisions they made
they are thrown adults and they have to
deal with the consequences of that and
that's not unkind but you guys have your
own journey ahead of you so you got to
put your mask on first before we go
helping them out so should they get
long-term care yes
if they can't afford it tough cookies
they're going to have to deal with some
really terrible health care in their old
age and i don't want that for them but
it's not on you to spend half of your
income trying to make sure that they're
taken care of while your family suffers
financially
you're doing great i needed to hear that
yes ma'am and leanne listen listen liam
you're doing great you and your husband
are doing awesome you're gonna be out of
baby step two before you know it and
you're gonna get in baby step three and
you guys are gonna be able to model this
to them
you just keep doing what you're doing
you're crushing it here's a gift for you
leanne we're gonna give you one year of
ramsay plus hang on kelly's gonna pick
up i want you to all watch the financial
peace universities uh videos together as
a family nine videos and get every
single person on a budget this is going
to be a fun family financial affair
three hours in there yeah leanne i'm
okay with you buying the popcorn buy the
popcorn for the videos other than that
they gotta do i like this that was this
hour of the ramsay show
in the books
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
ramsey personality george campbell
joined today by ken coleman best-selling
author and host of the ken coleman show
and we are taking your calls america if
you've got a question you need some
validation affirmation confirmation
motivation education we are here for you
and ken specifically focuses on career
your work your purpose what you were
born to do and he's going to help you
map out a plan to get you there and i
can help you with all things money and
generally ken they're intertwined it's
amazing how that works
to separate them yeah yeah an income
creates impact income means you can get
your financial goals accomplished and so
we are here for you open phones this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five joe kicks us off he's in
logan utah joe welcome to the ramsay
show
hi how are you great how can we help
um i'm just looking for
some advice on how to move forward a
little bit with
my life and with my family um
as quick of a background as i can
um
real quick uh
so i'm an apprentice electrician and
it's a four-year program and i'm done
with the schooling for the first year
fourth year i just need to
take the test um
but over the last few years
um i had
a company that they just kind of changed
their business model they didn't need
another apprentice anymore and
so they
they let me go and so i
went on to a another job in a in a
cabinet shop and
kind of worked out a thing with the
owner there that
you know potentially i could buy him out
when when he retired
um and after about a week of that he
realized that he doesn't have any of the
big equipment to move
the big sheets that they use and they're
like 80 to 90 pounds and eight feet long
and really awkward and i'm not a big guy
so he had to let me go just because i
wasn't
as big as him
joe you sound defeated have you been
kind of beat down at every turn you feel
like
yeah
i've got uh i've got a wife and two
beautiful little girls and
i feel like i've worked really hard and
tried to do everything right and
i don't feel like i can provide for him
okay so
let me go back just a bit you're about
ready to finish up your uh four-year
apprenticeship to be an electrician
when do you finish that up
and do you want to be an electrician
because it seems like that's a great way
to provide right now
well i i'm just waiting on some
i can't get a hold of them but i'm
trying to get some paperwork from my
previous employer
for what um and so that i can
go and take the state licensing test and
then i'll i'll be set okay so i'll have
my journeyman's license great and what
kind of money i'm sorry go ahead
um
anyways after that
cabinet job i started with another
company and they
i just feel like i got kind of burned
there and stabbed in the back a little
bit by some people that i trusted and i
got
asked to look for another job there as
well and so i just don't
that was kind of the straw that built
the camel's back for me i have no desire
to stay in the electrical field anymore
my dad's an electrician and and while
he's done okay
he also jokingly half-jokingly says all
the time he's still trying to decide
what he wants to be when he grows up
okay i see so he doesn't have a passion
for it and you're realizing that you
don't necessarily have a passion for it
either you just kind of fell into it
yeah yeah
so what are we doing to pay the bills
let's start there let's let's get stable
because it sounds to me like you're that
you're just beat down you're scared you
feel like a big failure none of which is
true you're not a failure and there's
nothing to be scared about if you get
busy so what do we have for employment
right now are you currently employed
yes i am i'm working right now okay
great are you are you bringing in enough
to take care of everybody
um
for right now we uh
ended up selling our hot we had moved to
idaho for one of these jobs and
when that ended we figured there wasn't
anything that we was keeping us there so
we
sold our house and moved back to utah
and we're just staying with my parents
while we're kind of on the industry and
trying to figure things out okay so the
point is is you got everything there's
we're not in a storm right now we're
just in some confusion is that about
right
yeah that's okay right so what do you
want to do joe
i know you got an idea in your head and
i if you're if you're insecure about it
i want you to shake all that off and
just tell me what is it that you would
like to do joe you've had to wonder
about it with all those crappy
electrician experiences and cabinet
making none of which you wanted to do
what do you want to do joe
um
well i do pretty i feel like i do pretty
well with people and and
public speaking kind of things but
so i'd like to work with people a little
bit and i love the outdoors so i'd like
to be in the outdoors industry in some
way going to
either
working or owning an archery shop or
working for a bigger outdoors company
and
trade shows for joe joe i like it now
we're moving somewhere now this doesn't
mean that this is the thing but i'm
jumping in really quick because our time
is limited with you and i want you to
hear what i just heard
you're really good with people you like
to connect with people so you want to do
people type work but you also love being
outdoors and you like the outdoor
environment did i hear this correctly
yes sir fantastic
i love the idea i would put it on the
list all right so right now it's almost
like we get out that old school poster
board george doesn't know what this is
because he's a millennial and george
back in the day we'd get a poster board
you could buy it in your grocery store
and you get out a marker and you just
kind of ideate on it and i think one of
the ideas joe is working for a large
outdoor retailer and you could be in
sales or you could be in customer
service maybe you could eventually get
into training all of those are people
focused work true or false
true
and you'd do pretty good at those things
wouldn't you just those three ideas true
or false
i think i could do all right come on joe
joe
you told me you were good with people
could you excel in those three types of
positions if you put your mind to it yes
or no
of course you could
so i like that idea
maybe you go to work for a large company
like that you get yourself you get your
confidence up you see your company like
that where you can grow you move up the
ladder you got good benefits you save
some money maybe you start a little
expedition side hustle where you're
taking people on guided hunting or
fishing trips or whatever am i starting
to say things you like joe
yeah a lot of ideas that i've played
with all right joe stop playing
stop playing and start doing stop
playing with the ideas and start doing
you understand so we're looking for a
job
that will allow you let's keep this
simple because this is what you're
looking for in job descriptions joe i'm
looking for a job where i'm very people
facing i'm spending most of my day
communicating with people maybe in a
sales role customer service role maybe
some type of training role but i'm just
i'm just communicating with people and
if i'm connected to the outdoors or i'm
doing that in the outdoors
all right now we got some juice
and now we build on that joe
hang on the line i want to give him a
copy of my best-selling book from
paycheck to purpose which will help
solidify this process that we just got
started joe hang on we're gonna get that
to you i'm excited for you joe more
breakthrough coming up right here on the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george camel joined today by ken coleman
and we are taking your calls
work money relationships you name it
it's your life and we are here to talk
about it in front of all of america and
it's a good time nate is joining us up
next he is in las vegas nevada nate
welcome to the ramsay show
hey george campbell with the k and not
just the
not just mr coleman but you were
listening to ken yesterday weren't you
yes i think so i was thank you for that
yeah i appreciate the mister but call me
ken the rest of the time
all right
what's going on with you nate how can we
help
hey so i've been listening for about
three years and i just want to tell you
guys thanks for the great job you guys
do and
me and my wife we
got out of debt and
everything's improved our marriage has
improved finances you know everything so
that's awesome
the whole shebang
fantastic
so but my question is and i haven't
heard about this before
um where
would you guys put
um a health savings account in your baby
steps is that part of your emergency
fund your full fund or
that considered part of an investment
thing
this would be somewhere in between it's
not really an emergency because if your
hvac goes out we're not going to go dip
into the hsa to pay for that
and it can be an investment
not hvac health savings oh yeah i heard
you say hsa but that's a health savings
account and so you said is this
concerned the emergency fund and there's
just too many other emergencies outside
of health so
we don't want to put it there and the
hsa is going to be a separate account
and where in the baby steps do you
contribute that's your question right
yes so what baby step are you guys on
currently
um so we're on four five six
and
we're currently doing 15 percent
um i guess that's another question in
the question we maxed out to roth we're
both self-employed
and so the remainder over the top of
that
um i don't know if
i should put in a step ira or a solo
401k yeah those are both great options
if you're self-employed and they have
real high contribution limits so i would
i would get in touch with the
smartvestor pro to figure out what
option is best for you based on your
business and your income and all that
stuff but you guys are doing great
so let's talk about this hsa have you
guys been contributing obviously you
have one you have a high deductible
health care plan
yeah that's correct um yeah we've we
contributed and maxed it out last year
um and we're planning on doing the same
thing this year i just don't know where
you know well we tell people
i want you to have enough to cover your
annual deductibles
in baby step four through six i
personally wouldn't be maxing it out
until you're in baby step seven with a
paid for house because all that extra
money needs to be going towards the
house
once you're in baby step seven you can
go hog wild and max it out
yeah so i guess we're in three b four
five six so we're saving for
a down payment but we're not pausing
retirement okay so your hsa is it maxed
out right now
you've got enough in there to cover your
medical expenses for the year
deductibles all that
um i think we're close to 100 years for
an individual but not for the family are
you guys pretty healthy
yeah yeah we're a young family with two
little kids
okay well i would dial back on the hsa i
wouldn't max it out i want you guys to
get that down payment i want you to make
sure you're investing 15 make sure we're
saving for college make sure we get the
house paid off and once you're through
all of that you're in the house the
house is paid for then i would be
focusing on maxing out the hsa as part
of my retirement investing strategy
because there's some great great tax
advantages there but right now it feels
premature to be maxing it out while
saving for the down payment and then
you're gonna want to pay off the house
so we just have too many goals going on
at once right now
okay so i would dial it back make sure
you have enough to cover your
deductibles beyond that let's throw it
at the down payment
okay
sweet and so
yeah after we start doing the hsa
um because once you get a certain amount
in there you can invest those into
limited investments would you you
recommend doing that as well oh
absolutely yeah find some good gross
stock mutual funds with a proven track
record in there and that's a that's a
great retirement solution because of the
tax advantages in there so that's a
great part of your portfolio long term
so i love you doing that but right now
we have some other goals too so yes
invest the money once it's past that
threshold beyond that let's get the down
payment in place thanks so much for the
call nate appreciate you moving on we
are going all the way to boston
massachusetts my hometown alex joins us
there alex welcome to the show
hey how's it going guys great how can we
help
all right so i'm 25 and i just started
my career i'm on the case to make about
120 000 this year
i have 16 000 in debt and 15 000 savings
uh i'm in a spot where my monthly
expenses are about 12 to 1400 but it's
not the nicest neighborhood how long
should i stay here and uh how much money
should i have before i start looking to
buy a hole
great questions man 25 making 120k in
boston way to go you have 15k savings 16
in debt so my question is how quickly
can you save up let's see if you put a
thousand aside that gives you 14 so you
need 2k more how quickly could you get
2k saved up and just pay all this debt
off
i just actually should get a better
just about that
great well our plan is the fastest
surest way to build wealth so if you're
following our plan baby step one
thousand dollar emergency fund you have
that that leaves you with 14. i would
throw all 14 at the 16k of debt leaving
you with 2k left and you're probably
going to free up some payments along the
way right what kind of debt is this
uh it's a car and credit cards okay
so
this is going to free up some payments
which is going to help you get that debt
out of your life even faster then i want
you to build back up your fully funded
emergency fund which is three to six
months of expenses you just told me
they're about 1400
that's great okay
so you're looking at what let's call it
ten thousand dollars to be safe
now we have ten thousand dollars then we
can focus on 3b which is where we save
up for the house down payment and in
boston that's going to be tough right i
mean what are what are places going
around your area that you'd want to live
uh let's say four to six
okay
so for talking 400 i would want you to
save up 10 20 as ideal to avoid the
private mortgage insurance pmi but let's
say you save up ten percent how quickly
could you then save up forty thousand
dollars making 120 a year with not a
payment in the world and a fully funded
emergency fund
probably less than a year boom yeah you
feel you feel the progress alex yeah i
like this but i i uh and alex george has
just beautifully walked you through the
the question and the answer to your
question but i have to know
um why do you feel like you need to get
a house anytime soon didn't you say
you're a young guy 20 yeah it's it's not
the 25 not the safest neighborhood
what neighborhood is it
uh
it's it's in lowell okay oh well you can
move do you work around there
i do yeah all right so here let me ask
it another way are you in a serious
relationship you think i mean you
planning to be married the next two to
three years
no no not tomorrow yeah well my point is
i'd rent
uh with all these new savings that
george just walked you through i'd
i'd rent in a nicer area and i would
stay renting until i knew
that i was ready to plant by by buying a
house i'm not against a single person
buying a house sure i'm just saying
until you know because here's my point
you could buy a house for you and then
you meet the you know the person of your
dreams and then they got an opinion all
of a sudden that's true i i just would
i'd hold tight i think you could save
the money like george is talking about
but but i wouldn't be in any kind of
hurry to buy i would just keep going
along and i want you to get the
emergency fund in place before you yes
how much more would rent be in a safer
area
uh-huh looking at around two
months compared to what what are you
paying now
uh right around 7 50.
oh wow that's a big jump you have
roommates
i don't know wow 750 in the boston area
is impressive if i'm a single dude uh
i'm getting a room yeah would you be
opposed to getting a roommate
um i i've lived alone for about a year
now i'm kind of lucky though
sure you like it but 2 000 is a lot for
you to be forking over to rent
right right that's my predicament so
there's a trade off there i don't want
your rent to be more than 25
of your take-home pay
yeah but you don't have the money for it
to be able to buy and you're looking at
a 30-year and i don't want you in debt
for 30 years man you're a young dude i
want you to be financially successful to
build wealth 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
10 to 20 down where the payment is no
more than a quarter of your take-home
pay when it comes to rent i want it to
be the same no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay because you've got
financial goals and i want you to hit
all of those and so we've got to do this
the smart way you're going to be all
right we'll get you out of the sketchy
area in no time follow the plan man this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ken
coleman
and on the debt-free stage in the lobby
of ramsey solutions chris and sarah join
us how are you guys good good where are
you coming from today richard virginia
wow
all the way to do a debt-free scream huh
yeah
how much debt did you guys pay off about
26 600. a wonderful and how long did
that take about 38 months
wonderful and what was the range of
income during that time uh we started
out about 42 000 uh got up to about 76
000 and i think right now we're set to
make about 65 this year awesome wow what
was the uh what do you guys do um so i'm
currently an rn at vcu medical center
and then
sarah works at a montessori kids
universe as a teacher yeah wonderful
well thank you for your both your public
service that's fantastic now tell us
about this debt 26 600 what was that
comprised of
mostly student loans and i debt to my
parents uh personal that oh personal
owner yeah that's that always makes
things interesting at thanksgiving right
all right so we have the student loan of
the person alone and you guys decided 38
months ago that you just didn't want to
have these hanging around your neck
anymore what happened 38 months ago um
so we just gotten back like from our
honeymoon uh
we had found a church we wanted to go to
uh my wife had
heard that they were going to do a
financial piece of university at the
church we were attending and um
she said hey i think we should do this
and i was like okay you know i feel like
we you know i was pretty good with money
but i was like you know won't hurt we
can always try to learn something yeah
as i i felt like because i grew up in a
house a similar principles to ramsay
and um
i was like when i we got back and spent
like i don't remember how much it was a
lot for groceries like
this
we're knowing something wrong here so
you gave chris the nudge of like hey hey
what if we went to financial peace
university yeah it could be fun at the
time i didn't know it was a dave ramsey
thing i'm just like oh something has to
do with finances we could use the
something to know about finances and
chris you were kind of hesitant about
this um
i mean i was willing to do it but it was
just a matter of like oh i feel like i
do money pretty well but yeah so you
thought you were crushing it with money
you're like i'm good i think i could
teach this class maybe not that good but
good good enough
but you guys went through it and it
clearly got you on the path
what was the journey like what were the
sacrifices along the way the hardest
parts the fun parts um i think at first
the biggest thing was just like
hey you know we need to cut back on
groceries because our like first grocery
bill was like 500
for the month for the weekend um
yeah we just wanted to save that money
up um
there was definitely some road bumps
along the way to say the least yeah
shortly after we
started the journey
we had put our emergency fund into this
online account but it wasn't very
reachable
and we were trying at the time to sell
some furniture and the bank we were at
at the time
uh it was uh some fraudulent checks and
they decided to shut all our
all of our accounts down and they froze
them yes they froze them yeah so it was
like all of our money was in limbo and
they basically told us hey you got to
leave you know we can't let you bank
here anymore so
wow you're getting kicked out of your
own bank yeah
they just say we don't trust them
anymore not to give away any names but
right right what does it rhyme with a
dress
there we go oh there we go oh boy okay
so i've got to learn about your shirts
they say you're going to want to give up
don't yeah um what does that mean well
it was just shirts that um the church
provided for us for financial peace
university so i think it's just a a
saying that's like basically you're
going to have some tough times you're
going to want to you know give up quit
walk away from it but you you know the
payoff is bigger than the sacrifice you
have to make in here and now what was
the hardest part for you guys um
probably just limiting ourselves like um
when we started out they were saying the
person who led it was like
you know you probably should have a
little bit of money to to
kind of spend on yourself you know just
a tiny amount and so we set it to be
like 40 a month you know for like a
movie or just to go out and eat once a
month or something like that so
that was kind of hard because every now
and then it's like oh it'd be nice to
just go to subway and it's like oh we
already spent that money
yeah and i think also um
just
getting
oh i forgot what was going to say
to the um
point where we were just
not
spending as much and getting
i think we started off dave ish and we
wanted to continue our
uh 401ks and um
uh this hill had our credit cards but
probably probably before
probably about week five or six in this
class we're like if we're going to do
this we got to do it right
in yeah yeah fish gets you ish results
that's not impressive well you guys did
this stuff what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is um just uh
sticking to it like
our budget doesn't change much month to
month we keep it pretty much the same
and just kind of providing encouragement
for each other
whenever we need it
and not giving up and i also think
trusting god to provide because i know
there was a few times where it was like
really tight and we were like where's
this money coming from when we get an
unexpected check or
um
like the stimulus checks definitely
helped us out too so
okay well you know what finally a
stimulus check onto something good
so i assumed you had a y in this picture
and i can hear her in the background and
brought her with us today of course
what's her name and age um arya and her
uh she's 10 months old
precious well she's here she's kicking
she's screaming she's ready to go i
think she's ready to go she's got that
free scream you guys have worked for it
we are so proud of you guys your heroes
love the shirts great encouragement
you're going to want to give up don't
it's that simple and it's that hard
i love it all right let's get to it
chris and sarah and arya from richmond
virginia
26 600 paid off in 38 months making 42
up to 76 back to 65. count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
that is how you do it a family tree
change yeah just like that absolutely
sacrifice diligence intentionality yep
all those words come to mind
way to go chris and sarah
all right guys if you're wondering
whether to buy or sell a home this year
i've got some answers you can expect the
market to be a lot like last year with
prices still on the rise but interest
rates are expected to go up to this year
so what can you make of all this well if
you're buying a home you might be up
against some heavy competition and some
hefty price tags we're seeing that all
over the country so if you want to sell
your home chances are it will sell
quickly and for top dollar which is
great of course that all depends on
where you are because every real estate
market is different but to win in any
market you really have to know what
you're doing this is not amateur hour
you got to work with someone who knows
what they're doing not your
brother-in-law who just got his real
estate license who's never sold a house
we have experienced real estate agents
at your fingertips through our local
endorsed local provider
endorsed local provider program these
are called ramsey trusted pros and they
care about your values and they care
about keeping more money in your pocket
they're going to do right by you and
they are the pros that we trust to help
you buy or sell a home so check out
ramseysolutions.com
agent to connect with the ramsey trusted
pro who can help you navigate your local
market that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash agent
wow the housing market can it's a
stressful one for a lot of people yeah
it really is a lot of fomo out there a
lot of people looking to sell but then
they gotta turn around and buy
and they go well they could get us out
of debt and so there's a lot of reasons
to sell these days
but at the top of the market
you gotta turn
yeah for that very reason you might sell
at the top but then you're going to
overpay for something so you know be
patient uh really think this kind of
stuff through and i also think i mean
you have certain areas of the united
states that are going to stay really
really hot i mean we saw that through
past recessions
but i think you're going to see a
resetting remember there's been a kind
of a pause a moratorium if you will on
delinquent house payments and renters
that's going away soon watch out gonna
be a lot of pain mark his words i'm
telling you it's just a fact it's coming
yeah we'll do it the right way and work
with a pro again this is not amateur
hour work with a pro knows what to do
and they can help you make the right
financial decision because let me remind
you it's the biggest financial decision
that's right you'll ever make don't go
it alone check out our agents
ramseysolutions.com
agent to find one in your area this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm george
campbell ramsay personality and host of
the fine print and entree leadership
podcast joined today by my good friend
ken coleman best-selling author and host
of the ken coleman show you can find all
those shows including this one on the
ramsey network and wherever you listen
to podcasts
barbara joins us up next she's in
virginia beach barbara welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call i really
appreciate it oh absolutely we're happy
to help what's going on
so i have two beautiful adult children a
son 33 and a daughter 31. my son is nice
and stable married and i'm waiting for
grandkids but my daughter just
celebrated her one year of sobriety oh
no i'm thrilled about that it's
wonderful she's in a great program um
but i'm asking my concern is that i have
not a lot but some 401k money some
beneficiary money through my pension
plan and when she was you know drinking
i i didn't give her any of the the
beneficiary any of the money i gave it
all to my son and we discussed the fact
that he might be able to be like a
keeper of the money so to speak if i
were to pass and and his sister was
still drinking but now that she's sober
i'm wondering should i put her back
um at 50 which was my original plan and
just a little caveat here they both
inherited money from the grandmother
when she passed
my son put his back into a 401k my
daughter spent all of hers as you can
probably figure somewhat of it on
alcohol
so
was a year sober under her belt
should i take that chance should i keep
it at
maybe 25
um and then hope that my son follows
through or just go 50 50 and take a
chance what's the conversation been like
with her about
what she would get if and when you
passed
i haven't actually discussed it with her
okay just my son is there some reason
that you because you said something a
minute ago you said should i trust that
my son will follow through
is there any reason to believe that he
wouldn't follow through on your wishes
no it's just that i'm thinking if if i
pass and she's back to drinking he would
hopefully keep that money for her but
you know there's no guarantee what's
going to happen otherwise he is very
trustworthy though and he's very
uh responsible so i think he would but
it's a lot to ask him for to be the
keeper of his sister's inheritance
i i think he's up to it i really do i
you haven't given me any evidence to
believe that he wouldn't be able to do
it you had the conversation with him
obviously correct
yes and he understood it totally was he
an agreement did he have questions or
that makes you think he doubts that it's
the right thing
no he was fine with it we didn't go into
a lot of detail
so i think
i think at that point he figured yeah if
she's drinking he doesn't want her to
blow through the money
like he did with his with her grandma's
but um i just you know
he is 33 he's an adult but at the same
time
it's a lot of responsibility so i mean
so the other idea was thinking should i
put it into a trust for her instead
with a caveat of she's got to be you
know x number of years sober for her to
touch it or i don't even know if i can
do that actually you can do whatever you
want
it's incredible what you can do there so
barbara how old are you
i'm 63. okay so you got you've got a
long ways to go here what i might do i
would have an honest honest conversation
with both of them and say hey listen i
want to leave you both uh the 401ks all
this when i pass i want to stair step
into this i love that you're sober i'm
so proud of you but i want to make sure
that i never become an enabler for you
or cause you to do any harm to yourself
so here's what i want to do
every year i'm going to increase the
beneficiary amount until it gets to 50
every year that you're sober and so that
way there's some incentive uh not that
this is what's keeping her from drinking
obviously i mean she's sober on her own
volition and i love that but it could be
a way to say hey every year we're going
to stair step this into it and in five
years time we're going to get to that 50
percent where she gets half
that's one way to do it that's a great
idea okay yeah and george i and i have a
question i'm kind of saying you're more
the you're the money guy and this could
i like the idea of her putting it in a
trust
because then that takes the
responsibility off of the brother and
the son so that she's not you know what
i mean where it's now it's not it's your
wishes and you legislated it through the
trust and the trustee is the one that
makes the decision based on your wishes
and it takes that off of him that might
be a good there's a relational component
here where it puts them in an awkward
position and i don't i don't know that
they would get in a quarrel if she gets
this percent and he gets this percent i
don't know what their relationship is
yeah it's it's tentative just because
they're restrained she's on the west
coast he's on the east coast and so they
don't have a lot of communication but
i'm hoping that will change now that
she's
uh you know sober and productive well
you're under no obligation to do
anything with this money you could give
it to a stranger on the street if you
want so anything they do get is an
absolute blessing from you and there's
nothing that goes well you're my mom so
you have to give me the money there's
none of that if there's that level of
entitlement then they're not getting it
so i think having the honest
conversation with them is key though
don't let this happen where they find
out after you pass and now it's a huge
fight that's not the legacy you want to
leave so i would have the conversation
as soon as possible and let them know
where things stand
okay perfect thank you so much i really
appreciate you guys thanks so much for
the call barbara
awesome all right let's move on to dan
he's in portland maine dan welcome to
the ramsay show
hey thank you very much for taking my
call absolutely
yeah so um so i'm a little late to the
old baby start plan uh or the baby steps
you're right on time man never too late
all right well i got the emergency fund
taken care of i got the focus on the
debts that all everything's paid off
except for the house
um
and but i happen to have two kids in
college
um so step five kind of snuck up the
list on me
and um
i took out a
uh heloc loan uh to kind of be a safety
net to cover the college to michigan
well hear me out here please
um so i took that out just to basically
have a
money to pay for school because i've
been working on paying uh paying down
everything and uh not you know i didn't
have an adequate emergency fund to
you know send big checks off to colleges
um but so now that you already said oh
no once i'm sure you're going to say it
even louder this next time but i just
want to hear your thoughts on it so i'm
thinking about where the heloc is in
adjustable interest rate and it's
probably going to start ratcheting up
and i'm looking at my 401k and it is
underperforming currently after having a
good previous year
and i'm thinking about taking out a loan
to wipe out oh no
damn damn
come on dude i was rooting for you you
had me in the first half
what's going on here you're robbing
peter to pay paul
you're talking about a safety net
debt is a terrible safety net
when you owe people money you don't have
safety
true wouldn't would it not be better
just to owe myself
no you're robbing from your future dude
you're 53 i want you to retire with
dignity your kids are gonna have to take
care of you after you you know died on
the sword to help pay for their college
so that you could go into debt
this is a terrible sacrifice
okay so i want you to put your own mask
on first and that means we're gonna get
you out of debt we're gonna get dan
investing 15 of his household income and
they can be on their own for college
you're under no moral obligation to foot
the bill
i know you want to and you can help
beyond the 15 after you're investing 15
and we this is after we pay off the debt
which means we are not investing until
this heloc paid off
and then we're going to start investing
15 and you can do catch-up contributions
as well at your age to help you get in
on on the right foot for retirement so
how much do you have in retirement right
now
uh about 400 000 okay that's comforting
i was hoping you would have a number
that had a few zeros on it so that's
good but we need to get that number a
little higher so that you can
retire and not be freaking out about how
you're going to pay the bills
yeah so the kids are on their own right
now and that's okay have the honest
conversation with them say hey kids i
want you to become debt free stay debt
free but right now dad's got to take
care of his debt he's got to take care
of his own retirement so that i'm not a
burden to you in 10 years in 15 years
and 20 years
any uh any thoughts on the fact that
basically
i have a seven year college span and
this is year five like basically the
oldest boy has already completely paid
off
well
you guys need to make a plan together
and that looks like scholarships and
part-time work and a lot of hustle but
at the end of the day it's on them the
decisions they make
wishing the best for you dan stick to
the plan don't do dan's plan do dave's
plan it's worked for millions of people
for 30 years that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books my thanks to
ken coleman all the folks in the booth
making the show happen and you america
we'll be back with you before you know
it
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world get your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print podcast joined
today by ken coleman best-selling author
and host of the ken coleman show and we
are here to take your calls answer your
questions and give you hope to give you
the next right step for whatever you're
dealing with in life so if you want to
talk work you want to talk money
relationships boundaries moving careers
moving states we are happy to talk about
it open phones at
825-5225
madison kicks us off she's in lubbock
texas madison welcome to the ramsay show
hi how are y'all doing great how can can
i help
all right so i just had a question i'm
still in college right now i only work
part-time
um
i don't have any debt i guess i'm in
baby steps four through seven
i invest about fifteen percent but that
doesn't you know i can only invest into
a roth right now
um and i'm not able to max out the roth
only doing fifteen percent
um i just don't know
what to i don't have many expenses or
anything so i'm just kind of wondering
what to do with all the money i've set
aside
madison you are incredible
you're 20 years old and you're talking
like someone who has a lot more wisdom
than most 20 year olds i run into so way
to go first of all
so how much money do you have saved
i have 40 000 in savings and that's
aside from my six month emergency fund
how did you save this money up
just throughout life i don't spend money
hardly do you have any fun i want to
make sure you're still having some fun
at 20 years old
yes i do i've got a few clubs and stuff
like that and i'm able to go out and do
some fun things with friends so okay how
long i'm curious because there's there's
a reason why i'm asking this how old
were you when you first started saving
money of that 40 000 how far back does
that go
um my parents actually set up that
savings account you know whenever we
were really little and all of our you
know birthday money and gifts like that
from grandparents went into it
um so when i was probably 18
it was at about 18 000. wow and then the
rest is just from
working part-time jobs babysitting dog
sitting just extra money i guess good
for you that's your parents got a hold
of these ramsey principles and they
instilled it in you and you said yeah
that makes sense
yes sir that's true god bless that's
incredible okay so let's talk about this
money how soon until you're done with
college you're 20 right now are you you
you're next year two years
uh i have a year and a half i graduate
december 23. okay now are you able to
cash flow the rest of your college
yes my college is paid for
fantastic well this money to me becomes
madison's adult fund when she's out of
college and you get a job what are you
studying right now
construction engineering fantastic great
field so if i'm you i'm going to keep
saving up money and that money will then
become a down payment on my first home
in fact you're it would not shock me if
you were able to pay cash for your first
house with your level of diligence
okay with that money should i just keep
putting it into savings or should i be
investing it somewhere so it can you
know grow a little faster or
how should that work i think if you're
graduating in a year and a half and we
don't know what life looks like i'm
gonna just park that in a high yield
savings account a money market account
you're probably gonna get a half percent
on that money but the point of that
money is not to make money right now the
point of that money is to give madison a
leg up when she leaves college and she
moves to where she's going to move and
work where she's going to work and she
can afford a house
in that area because of the diligence
that she's had for years and years and
years
okay awesome thank you very much yeah
and keep investing at 15 too that's
fantastic and as you get a job you're
gonna probably have a 401k
with that with whatever you do in
construction invest 15 percent of your
total income into those things in good
gross stock mutual funds
pay off the house early madison is going
to be a multi-millionaire by the time
she's in her 30s and 40s without
question that gets me excited for the
next generation ken i love it all right
let's move on to michelle in kansas city
michelle welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks for having me absolutely
what's going on
yeah so my husband and i are debt free
um we paid off about 46 000 last year
and have been saving for a down payment
on a house
and as you know the housing market is
crazy right now and we were wondering if
you recommend we wait for a house to
come up in our price range and kind of
sit tight with the money we have for the
down payment or if we should put some of
the money we have saved towards um
the down payment towards paying for a
master's degree in human resource
development for me instead
oh interesting so you're either going
with a house or education
yes but we could also um cash flow
the masters if if you prefer or you
recommend so you're saying you could put
the down payment on the house get a
house and still cash flow the master's
degree
uh yes potentially when the house that's
affordable pops open so they have to
wait a little bit
yeah so based on your budget i mean i
wouldn't go outside of that how much
money do you guys have right now
um so we have about 52 000 aside from
our 15 000 emergency fund
and we're hoping to put 40 000 toward a
house and then his parents were willing
to give us a twenty thousand dollar gift
toward our down payment wow so you'd
have 60 down
yes 60 why the masters
so i'm interested in changing careers
i'm in administrative role right now for
a university and i've always wanted to
work more in policy and so i feel like
the hrd would give me that opportunity
to kind of work in there and helping
people get a job they love
wow and so
my question is is the masters necessary
to get there
that's a good question um so i know the
certification in human resources is kind
of the industry standard
um and so i i recently started my
position so i kind of figured i needed
to stay there for a while to get some
longevity on my resume
and then thought this position allowed
me to kind of work toward a degree at
the same time
yeah here's my point i want you to do
your homework you're pretty clear on why
hr and what you want to do when you're
in hr but you need to find out if the
masters is necessary because if it's not
michelle guess what
that certification and relationship
building is going to be more than enough
for somebody as sharp as you and then
you don't have to spend that cash on
something that you do not need now if
you want to get it the fact that you
guys can cash flow it i got no problem
with you getting it but i i just would
never spend that time and money on
something that you didn't have to have
a good call there so michelle what's
your take-home pay
um so
together we net about 92 a year
okay
so have you done the math on what the
payment would look like
yeah so the whole degree is about 12
000. okay
so what i'm seeing for you is we're
looking at about a 1900 mortgage payment
max is what i'm comfortable with on a
15-year fixed
does that sound about right
yeah that's kind of what we were
thinking too which puts you guys at
about 280 for a house is that reasonable
for your area
yes and it's kind of tough to come by
that price range right now
um just with the market and everything
yeah well i would keep saving up keep
saving that down payment if you can get
70 down 80 down that'll help with your
budget and you go okay now we can get a
house for 310 and we're still going to
be in the clear we're going to be able
to afford this payment easily pay it off
easily cash flow our masters easily
that's what i want for you guys is to
have margin so yes be patient the
housing market's crazy work with a great
real estate agent and do it when the
time is right and no sooner appreciate
the call this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
here at ramsey we've walked with
millions of people and their families to
help them overcome their financial
stress and we found that money stress is
just one of all kinds of ways we
experience stress people struggle with
anxiety loneliness and stress all the
time and here's the good news our friend
dr john deloney has a new book available
for pre-order called own your past
change your future and it's selling like
crazy because everyone wants and needs
this book it's a not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness and you are in for a treat
when you read this book you're gonna
laugh you're going to cry it will
challenge you and if you take the steps
that dr john delaney outlines you will
be transformed
just like total money makeover
transformed so many lives when it comes
to money i think this book is going to
do the same for people's mental health
and wellness
own your past change your future will
show you how to deal with different
types of trauma how to get connected to
a community and make friends as an adult
and it'll show you the steps that you
can take to change your thoughts and
actions yes it's possible and here's why
you should pre-order today this is your
last week to pre-order to get the e-book
two weeks early that's right you'll get
the e-book on april 5th before the book
is even available to the public so
pre-order your copy of own your past
change your future for just 20 bucks at
ramsaysolutions.com
today
i'm george campbell joined today by ken
coleman you're listening to the ramsay
show
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five we are headed
to medford oregon jason joins us there
jason welcome to the show
what's up gentlemen thanks for taking my
call yeah how's it going how can we help
well um in kind of a vehicle situation
here i have a 2013 chevy malibu it has
about 200 000 miles so it's kind of
towards the end of its life but still
runs well
it needs about 2 000 in repairs for an
ac compressor and another
piece
for check engine light that needs to be
replaced so all together it's about two
grand i did some shopping about four or
five different places
found the cheapest one
uh it does get about 110 up here in the
summer so i think right now i can wait
on the compressor but the other piece is
about 500 so i'm wondering my question
uh
my fear is i guess if i put the two
grand into the vehicle that's probably
worth about three
that something bigger could happen
and then i'm kind of stuck and so i
don't know
i don't have any debt besides my wife's
vehicle and our home no consumer debt
uh but i don't want to get into a
payment
we have about 40 grand in savings
so i don't know what you guys think
i should do so how much money did you
say you have in savings
about 44 000 wow
and how much of that is your emergency
fund
uh it's kind of everything all together
that's what we just have in our savings
it's kind of like emergencies three to
six months that's just our nest egg
basically while we still kind of work on
baby step two which is getting rid of
her
vehicle which she owes about 17 000 on
my wife's car okay that's what i was
confused about because if you're
following our plan you're gonna have a
thousand dollars in baby step one and
then everything else is gonna go towards
the debt in baby step two
right so how much is the total debt
seventeen thousand for the vehicle my
wife's
car and there's no other debt besides
our home okay so here's what i'm
thinking
why don't we pay off the debt today
right
which leaves us
with twenty seven thousand dollars
which a big chunk of that is going to be
your emergency fund right
and then whatever's left we upgrade you
to a better car
i don't think it's worth putting two
grand into a car that is worth three no
unless you're going to recoup the repair
cost which i doubt it's going to bring
the car up to a 5 000 or more value
with 200 000 right that's my biggest
concern is that you know if i fix it and
the air is running great and the car is
running great and the transmission blows
or something bigger happens and i've
wasted that two grand which i could have
put into it yeah
but jason we're telling you not to do
that so what's your six what is uh three
months what's uh three months emergency
for you guys three months of income
what's the number
probably
about maybe six to seven thousand
okay let's call it 10 just for round
numbers here which leaves you with 17.
so you can go sell your car for what one
or two grand at this point
i think a kelly blue boot could be about
three grand but that's not that's
assuming that the ac is not working i'm
sure that would drop it a little bit
yeah sell it for what it's worth right
now with all the things you take that
cash and you put it on top of the 17
that george walked you up to right
because you've now paid off your wife's
car and you guys have no debt emergency
fund in place and you have a much better
car and you don't even have to spend 17
plus plus because you let's say you get
1500 for the for the uh the malibu okay
so
now you got 18 five you could buy a nice
ten thousand dollar car if you wanted to
and you and then you still pad your uh
your emergency fund why yeah so
with us laying this out why wouldn't you
do that
no i think that's the best thing i think
that's kind of what i was talking myself
into i just get a little nervous you
know with the 44 being all we have
besides our investments and my 401k but
you're not even completing engine at all
you're still going to have 20k sitting
and you have a nice emergency fund and
if you want it to be closer to six
months just get a cheaper car and go all
right i'm gonna buy a 8 000 car yeah
right so we can have 30 in there okay
well you guys pretty much made me feel a
little bit better about the decision
because i didn't want to put that much
into the vehicle which i feel like is
kind of heading towards the end
yeah i'm with you man but you gotta you
gotta follow our plan or you can follow
jason's plan and i'll tell you our plan
works and it sounds like jason's plans
on the fritz this car is not doing so
hot
so i'm not gonna put the repairs in
let's just sell it let's get a better
car let's pay off the debt today never
go back into debt again and you've got
the pad because this emergency fund
exists today you got this all right
let's go to alfred in houston texas
alfred welcome to the show
hey what's going on nothing much man how
can we help
okay so i'm in baby step number two
right now and i've kind of run into like
a not a problem but a decision to make
so i have a
i have a balance on a credit card that's
3 500
and then i have another one that's 4 500
but the one that's thirty five hundred
dollars
i think i have a judgment on it
so i don't know
i don't know how to approach this
because i haven't even come into contact
with them is that all of your debt yeah
so far i'm ready towards the end i've
been at it for like three months now
okay so you've got 8 000 left in credit
card debt and that's it
yes how much money do you have right now
to your name
uh well now i have about 1500 bucks
that's with my emergency phone so let's
call that your baby step one a thousand
dollars everything outside of that we
need to be thrown at this debt what do
you know about this judgment did it go
to collections
yeah it happened like when i was 18. i'm
23 now uh this is five-year-old texas
yeah this is an old day whenever i was
yeah okay here's what i want you to do i
want you to be proactive and get on the
phone with them with the collection
agency have them verify this debt in
writing which means they need every
single detail that tells exactly what
kind of debt this is what was paid the
charges and if they can't provide that
they have to throw it away illegally so
once you get that letter in writing i
want you to get on the phone and say hey
i'm willing to give you money this is a
five-year-old debt i've got 500 bucks
that's it that's all i can do will you
settle for 500
okay and chances are they're gonna do it
they may go a little higher but you got
to be ready to pay on the spot so i'd be
stacking cash right now as much as you
can working your tail off no
no install no installment plans do not
give them access to your checking
account under any circumstances
no
no right now this debt's been sitting
there dormant right you haven't been
paying anything on it that's why i went
to no yeah i haven't even yeah i haven't
come in contact since it's happened so
you may have a chance at negotiating but
the end of the day this is your debt and
you owe it so whatever they say they say
here's what we can do to settle it say i
want to settle this thing in full as a
lump sum i've got 500 bucks and see what
they say
and once you negotiate that debt
whatever it is they may say a thousand
and you've got that money in cash ready
to go pay off that debt and then move on
to that last credit card and then please
for the love never go into credit card
debt again can you promise me that
don't touch debt once you pay all that
off we're building the emergency fund
we're going to build for the future
instead of paying for the past that's
going to give you some great footing
some great foundation so you can start
building your life man you're so young
you got your whole life ahead of you we
gotta stop playing games and i'm rooting
for you yeah call us back when you're
dead free okay
yes sir love to hear it there we go
another one in the books good stuff
there give us a call triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's talk
about your work your money all the
things that matter to you what you're
worried about excited about the highs
and lows of life that's what we're here
for i'm george campbell joined by ken
coleman this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by ken coleman
and in the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the debt free stage brandon and madeline
join us how are you guys good how are
you where you from
from uh brunswick maine we're currently
living in connecticut though lovely new
englanders i like that big fan okay so
how much debt have you guys paid off um
we've paid off 90. just drive 91 000.
fantastic how long did that take
approximately 18 months
what was your range of income during
that time
um our range of income was approximately
120 and bumped up to about 138 awesome
what do you guys do for a living
i'm in the marine corps and i'm a nurse
fantastic well thank you for your
service both of you incredible okay so
you guys look pretty young am i right
thank you
yes okay i won't ask ages yet yet but
we'll get there
sharp couple here if you're watching on
youtube so
what type of debt was this 91 000
um
we had student loans debt um car
payments and a credit card um
so you were pretty much normal yeah you
just learned early on that you live life
with payments everyone's got a car loan
payment everyone opens the credit card
at 18 to build a credit score everyone
gets a student loan and you decided 18
months ago that you weren't going to be
normal anymore you weren't going to be
average what happened i got got you guys
on this journey well i had a dave ramsey
total money makeover book at home that
my dad gave me when i was like 17.
hadn't read it and then brandon we were
thinking about getting married and he
had read it and he was really big into
it so i read it oh that kind of started
so it was a coaster for a while and
you're like oh yeah i think my dad gave
me i think that sounds familiar it's on
my bookshelf it does anyone not you
should really you should read this yeah
was it was that your nudge to go like
hey if you want to if you want to be
married to me like we got to get on this
plan kind of i was very like oh we'll
just pay it off it'll be great and he's
like well what's the plan i was like
well we'll just pay it off it'll be
great and he's like what's the plan he's
a marine he needs a plan okay so how
long you guys been married uh
about 19 months oh wow so as soon as you
guys got married you got started on this
plan yes you got back from the honeymoon
and went for it we started before we got
married i feel like we were we were both
doing it on our um our own and then once
we got married we wanted to start the
marriage off on the right foot it was
super important to us that
we were on the same page and we could um
get going in the right direction from
day one that's incredible so you guys
were both on board day one did you feel
the momentum when you guys combined
finances and went okay this is our debt
now we're attacking all this together
yeah that was um very significant
because like she said i had the book too
when i was younger it was funny the uh
one of the i think there's a second car
loan i got the loan officer actually
gave me the book when i signed that day
wow was he like throwing shade like hey
son you may want to read this no i think
she was just trying to push people in
the right direction um i read it and
just couldn't gain a lot of traction was
doing what i could and um but
combining income really made a
significant impact for us and pushing
through and getting to where we are now
wow that's incredible so i gotta ask for
couples especially i love hearing we got
two different world views in some sense
right coming together different
experiences in life now here we are
we're married we're gonna do this thing
um how long did it take before you
really sense momentum can you remember
back like how long to figure it out
i guess i'm speaking for myself but i
thought it was right away because i
the
i felt like the most encouraging part
throughout it was having him to talk to
about it and we were encouraging for one
another and just talking about paying it
off and our plans for the future was
really encouraging
the snowball helped yeah um we all had
we had a lot of those little federal
loans and seeing those go away fast was
super encouraging it wasn't until we got
to
my parent plus loan that was essentially
half of the debt and that was the last
piece and we were like all right we got
to climb this this hill and then i'll be
there yeah wow that's incredible so what
was the hardest part of this journey
um for me it was driving my 06 corolla
yeah
i paid cash for that after we moved from
connecticut we got married
moved from california to connecticut and
got married i sold
my suv and i had that part paid off but
i needed
a cash vehicle and we didn't have a
whole lot of income after cash flowing
the wedding so wow that was hard for me
and
uh probably getting married and like
wanting to like set up a house and get a
nice apartment do all the fun new year's
fun stuff
like we're gonna wait we're gonna wait
we are broke yeah which was worth it
because all the stuff i thought i liked
i don't actually like anymore so wow
worked out well nice yeah so now you're
debt-free and you know how you want to
decorate right
this is an attitude a little while in
marriage you know people want to rush in
and do all the stuff you don't even know
each other yet i know i got to ask is
there a fun sacrifice or something crazy
like maybe you ate that you'll never eat
again i mean like how intense was this
anything like that
we really like to eat out we do really
like to eat out um that was one of the
that was probably the hardest part for
us together it's just friday saturday
nights um we probably went out to eat
more than we should have yeah but we
um paying attention to the budget and
realizing how much we were spending on
restaurants at the beginning and then
cutting that back and really seeing it
that
um
every dollar budget app is great and
that really helped us with the
communication and seeing and making the
progress that we needed to that's
awesome awesome so what do you tell
people especially young couple like you
sitting there with almost six figures in
debt and they're going well we'll just
never pay it off what do you tell them
the key to getting out of debt is
i mean probably talking about it like
where do you spend your money like why
let me why are you buying the beauty
products or like why are you buying the
fly fishing stuff like
like why do you really need it like and
communication yeah accountability
non-confrontational but like pleasant
like you know do you really need it and
i don't know and then just communicating
the communication portion um especially
with the budget and looking at it and
seeing what's important and where we can
cut and yeah i'm having those
conversations at the beginning of the
month and just knowing that going into
it we had a plan
we did really well certain months in
certain months we struggled but at least
we we could see where we needed to make
strides the following month and
just get better along the way and we did
you guys are inspiring we're so proud of
you do you guys have any cheerleaders
along the way
i mean
yeah our parents were super supportive
and then over here to my right is the
o'neill family stephen isabella i served
with steve in in california and um he
and i would listen to the podcast every
day in the shop and and we both were
very encouraging as we progressed
through our journeys he's deaf free
himself and it's really awesome to get
to stand here and have him with us today
so that's fantastic thank you both for
your service that is absolutely
incredible great enough to see them uh
get debt free stay debt free have
financial peace that's incredible okay
so we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you and at your age
that is absolutely the next step you
guys are going to be millionaires before
you know it and we also have a copy of
the total money makeover for you to give
to someone for it to sit on the
bookshelf for a little while here's a
fun treat put a sneak a 20 bill maybe
even 100 bill on a random page and then
see when they get in touch with you and
tell you hey thanks for 100 did you mean
to put this in here that's how you know
they read it
that's a little easter egg ken well
george it's a brilliant idea thank you
that drive me crazy they're waiting on
the call
that's true yeah they're gonna do it
they're gonna do it still struggle with
it well we're so proud of you guys so
glad that you made the trip from new
england to join us today and we've got a
little one with us today yeah who's this
that's our baby boy ander he's seven
weeks old
how does a seven week make the trip he's
dressed in his sunday best he is i love
the panties i love the cat
he's on the little girl it was a long
drive but
oh you drove yeah that's impressive
well we appreciate it and what's the
name and age ander he's seven weeks
andrew at seven weeks just precious you
gotta watch on youtube to see this
okay you guys have put in the work
18 months of a slog
very impressive it's brandon and
madeline and ander from the new haven
connecticut area 91 thousand dollars
paid off in 18 months making 120 up to
138 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one we're
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's funny he was awoken by the
sound of debt freedom is there a sweeter
sound that's a great little picture
there thank you and uh i think i think
we've got is that from braveheart the
sound
there we go all right james saying don't
mention that now the fcc is going to be
on
it's fine oh boy i'm inspired by couples
like that ken i am too you know why
because of that little dude you know
they did all that work here he is he has
no clue uh how much sacrifice his mom
and dad have made
to set him up and uh and also
you know that's a marine over there yeah
that's pretty stinking cool too it's
rock and roll yeah love to see it
appreciate you guys being with us love
to hear stories like that hey you can be
dead free too you can be the next
brandon madeline on this stage but it's
gonna take some work and sacrifice but
it is always going to be worth it this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
proverbs 21 5 the plans of the diligent
lead surely to abundance but everyone
who is hasty comes only to poverty
henry david thoreau said what you get by
achieving your goals is not as important
as what you become
by achieving your goals oh i bet ken
coleman loves that one i do like that oh
that's a good it's really good because
it's about the journey it's about the
process right yeah it's the achievement
kind of when you get there you're kind
of like huh i achieve but i'm still the
same person per se as it relates to your
lot in life but you're a better
uh individual you're more complete
you're more skilled you're more
experienced whatever it is yeah and it
ties back to that proverb you know you
get rich quick it didn't really change
your character but you put the sacrifice
in to get out of debt to invest overtime
consistently man that changes you know
james doesn't just pull those randomly
george he picks those because they fit
together james is a genius even though
he doesn't choose them but it's fine
no it's ours it's our friend dawn she
works very well that's unfortunate i
need to pay attention to my production
notes
and with that let's go to the phones
that's where ken's better off cara joins
us there she is in phoenix arizona cara
welcome to the ramsay show
yes hi i have a question for you guys um
we love questions about when
the question i ask kelly is when do i
start feeling the financial piece that
dave talks about because i'm in four
five and six and i still don't feel very
peaceful in my budget why
well i don't know and i think it might
just be a contingent thing like you were
talking about yesterday but we i mean we
bring home 120 000 well our income is
120 000.
we're investing 15 percent we have a
hundred dollars going into the 529s for
the kids we have the buy weekly monthly
mortgage payments so we're paying that
off faster but at the end of the month
we might only be able to save like three
or five hundred dollars after all the
investments for like our next vacations
or for christmas or for the next car we
need to buy and we're thinking about
having baby number three and it just
feels like we don't have enough extra
money to do all those things i don't
know
oh so cara tell me about your debt-free
journey how stressful was that where you
started well it was it was a little
different because i've always been
debt-free and i married my husband i
took my savings account we wiped out his
debt and then when he wanted to get his
master's degree we moved in with my
parents and we cashflowed the whole
thing
so you guys have been in go mode for a
long time
yeah i didn't have a typical baby step
two when we after we lived at my parents
house and paid for
his degree in cash we bought our house
and then
i don't know it just kind of our budget
is different than most people who like
rolled their debt into
their savings i don't know so if i hear
this correctly you're doing all the
steps it's great but you you don't have
as much money as you'd like to be able
to save to be able to spend to do some
things that you want to do so are your
other expenses too high or do you guys
just not have enough income based on
where you are in your
um in your part of the world i just
don't see phoenix being that crazy so
what's missing here
yeah i don't know i mean daycare is
super expensive i have two kids under
five and we both work full time so
that's more than our mortgage right
there that's like a 1500 monthly
and maybe that'll be gone
in a year or so
well when does the first one go to
school
um
a year from this fall so it's still
2023 in the fall
but then that's when we're thinking but
if we have another baby
that's just more
i don't know we want to have more kids
but we feel like we can't afford it
which feels weird because we're
debt-free and we make six figures yeah
you can afford it it's just it feels
like a crunch right now what if you guys
dialed back on the extra mortgage payoff
temporarily
well yeah and that's what i was
wondering is okay and another part of my
question is would it be crazy if we
dialed back on investing instead of
fifteen percent put it down to like
ten or eight yes that would be crazy buy
a new car i don't want your sweet kids
to have to take care of you in your old
age because you dialed back investing to
take care of them
i thought if i didn't listen to ramsay
and yesterday i got a car loan today
dave ramsey would tell me to stop
investing to pay off the car loan so
that's kind of where i was coming from
yeah but george you don't have any debt
george you told you to slow george will
you slow down on your on your extra
mortgage payment yeah yeah that's
different that's baby how much is that
so let's just be real practical
well wait a second an extra mortgage
payment feels like it's only 600 every
six months that doesn't seem that much
but like every month we're putting
fifteen hundred dollars into retirement
that's right so let me ask you okay
so let me ask you another question what
are some other options for the child
care that don't cost as much as you're
paying right now what are some other
options
i mean i don't know we haven't really
looked into other options i'd be looking
into other options
you know what i'd be thinking i'd be
going what if we found a really awesome
grandmother who maybe her grandkids live
two or three states away she's retired
she's very responsible she wants
something to do what would it cost to
pay her to watch our kids versus the
very expensive child care just something
to think about yeah i would be doing a
budget audit i'd go through are you guys
doing a monthly budget and sticking to
it yeah we're on every and that's kind
of where my husband gets stressed from
he's like how can we only have a few
hundred dollars when we go over the
budget when we're well
you guys are responsible when the
money's just floating away into spending
you're like we're having a great time
and we're not saving for college and we
have nothing in retirement
you guys are in great shape budget every
dollar i'm on it okay i think there's
two issues here and i was just kind of
trying to brainstorm for you but i would
be looking to cut expenses in the child
care if possible and then i would be
going wait a second let's make some more
money
you guys want really awesome vacations
then what can the hubs do as a weekend
side hustle from time to time and pay
for vacation if he worked and i'm just
making this up but if he were to go to
pick up a landscaping job during a
really you know intense season where
it's busy or
manual labor and he makes four or five
grand over two three months or we just
paid for vacation do you see what i'm
saying like instead of being stressed
why don't we get busy why don't we go
okay we want a four thousand dollar
vacation i'm making that up or or
whatever then we go okay how do we get
that
over and above what we're already doing
because you're doing everything right
yeah and if you have those singing funds
in place you may not have a ton of
margin but when it comes time to go on
that vacation the money's sitting there
so yes you may not have tons of money
extra but that's because you're putting
it you're giving it a name and that's
going towards the vacation you're
getting ahead i think you guys need a
perspective change i think you need to
see yourselves not as we don't have
enough left to spend each month as
opposed to going we're being very
disciplined and we're getting ahead and
we're making traction every month now if
we want some extra money
go make it
go make some extra money he's a
therapist i think he could pick up more
hours for sure of course he could need
his job
and shop around your your insurance
rates go through every single line item
every single premium and go are we
getting the best rate let me check
because you do that you do that with
your cable your internet hey you cut
some things that's a great point we have
a great do we still have that coverage
checkup tool yeah ramsay solutions dot
com slash checkup it'll tell you it'll
tell you what insurance you actually
need what you don't need and you can i
mean you may save a hundred bucks
you know maybe more but hey but i'd be
going through with a fine-tooth comb in
every piece of my budget going how can i
shave this down that child
i'm gonna tell you something
and i'm passionate about this
because we were fortunate to not to have
to pay for child care but there were
times where stacey did work where we did
but we went the the non-traditional we
found older ladies who we trusted who we
knew
and we saved a lot of money child care
is insane how expensive it is so
expensive yeah it is if you could cut
costs there that would be massive and
remember it's not forever so this is not
the next 30 years before you know it the
kids in school but
i i would look the retired grandmother
out somebody wants to make a little
extra money oh we got a lady jumping up
and down in the lobby she's like that's
me sign her up you know does she want to
move to phoenix um i don't think so
she's literally sprinting after one of
her grandchildren and she's going to
pull a muscle george i can't vouch for
her i don't know her yeah but yeah i
don't know her i want you guys to to
look back at what you've accomplished
and write it all down write the things
that you're proud of that you've
accomplished write down the things
you're grateful for
i think that will help you create some
of this contentment in your life that
you're that you're jonesing for because
a lot of people listening are going oh
my gosh i wish i had that income oh my
gosh i wish i was debt-free yeah too
much i had their problems i got to tell
you something carrie you're a rock star
you're your husband because you're
walking the baby steps out can i just
tell you you need to remove can't
you said the word can't two or three
times you can save up money for your
vacation you can make extra money for
christmas you can do all those things
get busy
oh
little mic drop there from ken coleman
to end today's show
not mad about it all right well that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books my thanks to my fantastic co-pilot
ken coleman all the folks in the booth
kelly ben james nathan zach andrew you
name it they're in there making the show
happen and you america we appreciate you
listening we couldn't do the show
without you until next time remember to
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you